my main reason was the failure to labor
to honor certain elements of social
democracy and I felt that you know I was
very disenchanted from labor right from
the business of the Iraq war which I
thought was a highly illegal war and the
war that no real labor party should have
got self involved in and I didn't like
blares attitude towards the fact he got
us in that and it seemed to me that that
the SNP and as you save quite firmly I
was a very very loyal and labor
supporter but the SNP seemed to be the
ones who were actually the keepers of
the Social Democratic flag and when I
was in Scotland during the referendum it
was it became clear to me that labor had
been so become so disconnected and
certainly in my hometown the the sense
of disillusion with the Labour Party was
so deep and so profound because it's the
poorest people who have suffered and
it's the poorest people that Labour have
not helped particularly in Scotland so
for you it's not really the primary idea
of breaking away from the united kingdom
of independence in that sense it's the
social policy very much so on it it's
also to do with the fact that you know I
think the independence issue is of
course there but I don't think in this
current election it's it's to the fore
and I think quite rightly so I think
Nicola has made that very clear I think
nickel has shown she's been exemplary in
her and a whole handling of the
selection i had just listened to Alex
was saying earlier on and I think that
that what we can do what we can do in
Scotland is we can move things to a much
more progressive if not federal sense of
politics I mean this election seems to
me it's more about the individual
constituency than actually about overall
kind of party views and I think that
what we're going to see is the
constituencies are going to surprise us
all I mean like in solihull like the
main the main challenges from the greens
and yet and the in the neighboring place
it's from it's from the it's from the UK
so it's it's quite interesting what's
happening in that way I think it's very
unusual and I think the paradigm of
politic
is shifting and hopefully shifting
towards a situation where the the
northwest and the Northeast can be
properly represented I always said even
during the referendum campaign that the
referendum was as much about England as
it was about Scotland and of course the
fact that people like John Major who
behaved so few Delhi toward Scotland and
and Cameron who has been almost
hypocritical in the fact that he was
asking us to please stay please stay
please stay but please stay only under
these conditions I find astonishing and
you know ridiculous quite frankly yeah I
mean you lived all over the world you
have a basin in England as well as an
interest in English politics and yet I
mean what would you say to English
people and they're really politicians
across the spectrum in England who say
well look you can't in the end say that
a party that wants independence that
wants to break away can be treated like
the greens or UK poor what are the
Liberal Democrats or whatever one of the
other parties that wants to play within
the system of the United Kingdom I think
the system we have to do with the system
as it stands there was a no vote we
didn't get independence this time but I
think it's a while before we're going to
come around to it again but I do think
you know I was I was very much a diva
max person and I was actually forced to
become an independent I'm quite proud of
the fact i became independent but what I
do think is the independent issue is
down the track a little bit I think what
we have to deal with is we have to deal
with and it behooves us to deal with our
English brothers and sisters is really
sorting sorting sorting British politics
out once and for all and British
politics are very an error and a very
very sad state but also the opposite of
that the paradox of that is it's the
paradigm is shifting and it's that
paradigm which is that the Scots can
help kind of move into a certain and
into a much more progressive area and so
therefore I think niccola's handling of
this whole election campaign has been
quite brilliant because it's clear she's
not she's dealing with Westminster
politics that
the priority not independence Ron Cox
thank you very much indeed for joining
us